حرب الانتصار على إسرائيل،
هي حرب مصرية،
بعد حربين الأولى كانت خاسرة، والثانية كانت للاستنزاف،
جاءت الحرب الثالثة للانتصار ورد الاعتبار،
ولأخذ الانتقام من المحتل الصهيوني،
آخر حرب اجتمع فيها العرب صفا واحدا ضد العدو،
هجوم مباغت للمصريين على جيش العدو،
توغل في الأراضي المحتلة،
أعقبها استعادة للأرض المحتلة،
انتصرت مصر وانتصرت سوريا بانتصار مصر،
لينتصر العرب عموما...
(حرب أكتوبر، للقصة بقية)
في عام ١٩٦٧، حدثت حرب النكسة العربية،
عندها سقطت الجولان السورية وسيناء المصرية ب
بيد العدو الإسرائيلي،
بدأت حينها حرب الاستنزاف، أو ما تسمى بحرب الألف يوم،
بينما تقدمت المدرعات الإسرائيلية صوب مدينة بور فؤاد
بهدف احتلالها يوم 1 يوليو، 1967،
تصدت لها قوة من الصاعقة المصرية بنجاح
فيما عرف بمعركة رأس العش.
تصاعدت العمليات العسكرية خلال الأشهر التالية
خاصة بعد مساندة العرب لدول المواجهة
أثناء مؤتمر القمة العربية في الخرطوم،
ورفض إسرائيل لقرار مجلس الأمن 242
الداعي لانسحاب إسرائيل من الأراضي العربية
التي احتلتها عقب انتصارها الخاطف على العرب خلال حرب يونيو.
استمرت الحرب نحو ثلاث سنوات،
وخلالها استهدفت غارات سلاح الجو الإسرائيلي
المدنيين المصريين أملا في إخضاع القيادة السياسية المصرية،
مستخدمين في ذلك مقاتلات الفانتوم الأميركية الحديثة.
كما استعان المصريون بالخبراء السوفييت وصواريخ الدفاع الجوي السوفييتية
لتأمين العمق المصري. وشهدت الحرب أيضًا
معارك محدودة بين إسرائيل وكل من سوريا والأردن
والفدائيين الفلسطينيين. وفي 7 أغسطس، 1970
انتهت المواجهات بقرار الرئيس عبد الناصر والملك حسين
بقبول مبادرة روجرز لوقف إطلاق النار.
ولم تؤد الحرب إلى أي تغييرات في خطوط وقف إطلاق النار
بعد خسارة حرب ٦٧، أصدرت القيادة المصرية توجيهات تقول
(أن نموت جميعاً في مواقعنا الدفاعية
أشرف لنا من وصمنا بالعار،
ووصمة الشرف العسكري هي التي  سنتحلى بها)..
وكانت حرب الاستنزاف أطول الحروب بين العرب وإسرائيل،
وهي أول صراع مسلح تضطر إسرائيل فيه إلى الاحتفاظ
بنسبة تعبئة عالية ولمدة طويلة
وهو ما ترك آثاره السلبية على معنويات الشعب الإسرائيلي واقتصاد الكيان...
القوات الإسرائيلية فقدت خلال حرب الاستنزاف أربعين طيارا
و827 فردا في القوات البرية و3141 ما بين جريح وأسير.
وفي المجال الاقتصادي زاد حجم الانفاق العسكري بما مقداره 300 في المئة
تحملها أفراد الشعب الإسرائيلي..
أما عن الجانب المصري فلم يكن يهتم إلا بالتدريب الجاد الشاق
للوصول إلى أعلى درجات الكفاءة القتالية انتظارا للحظة الحسم،
وهنا بدأت حرب أكتوبر
"حرب العاشر من رمضان" كما تعرف في مصر،
أو حرب يوم الغفران يوم كيبور لدى اليهود...
وكانت إسرائيل في الحرب الثالثة قد احتلت شبه جزيرة سيناء
من مصر وهضبة الجولان من سوريا، بالإضافة إلى الضفة الغربية التابعة للأردن،،
ومع بداية الحرب حققت القوات المصرية والسورية أهدافها،
ففي الأيام الأولى للمعارك، عبرت القوات المصرية قناة السويس
بنجاح وحطمت حصون خط بالريف
وتوغلت 20 كم شرقاً داخل سيناء،
بينما حاولت قوات العدو فتح ثغرات للجيش المصري لكنها فشلت،
وعلى الرغم من أن الولايات المتحدة مدت جسراً جوياً لإسرائيل
بلغ إجمالي ما نقل عبره 27895 طناً،
في حين مد الاتحاد السوفييتي جسراً جوياً لكل من مصر وسوريا
بلغ إجمالي ما نقل عبره 15000 طناً.،،
لم تثنِ قلة الدعم رجال مصر عن تحقيق انتصاراتهم،
انتهت الحرب رسمياً مع نهاية يوم 24 أكتوبر،
خلال اتفاق وقف إطلاق النار الموقع بين الجانبين العربي الإسرائيلي،
ولكنه لم يدخل حيز التنفيذ على الجبهة المصرية فعليّاً حتى 28 أكتوبر.
على الجبهة المصرية حقق الجيش المصري هدفه من الحرب
بعبور قناة السويس وتدمير خط بارليف واتخاذ أوضاع دفاعية،
وعلى الرغم من حصار الجيش المصري الثالث شرق القناة،
فقد وقفت القوات الإسرائيلية كذلك عاجزة عن السيطرة
على مدينتي السويس والإسماعيلية غرب القناة.
تلى ذلك مباحثات الكيلو 101 واتفاقيتا فض اشتباك،
ثُمّ جرى لاحقاً بعد سنوات توقيع معاهدة السلام بين مصر وإسرائيل
في 26 مارس/آذار 1979،
واسترداد مصر لسيادتها الكاملة على سيناء وقناة السويس....
هكذا يكون الانتصار ورد الاعتبار، فعندما أراد أبطال مصر استرداد حقهم،
انتصروا في المعركة، مع أن عدوهم يمتلك أقوى وأفضل الأسلحة المتطورة،
ودعما غير محدود من أقوى دولة في العالم حينها أميركا،
لكن العرب لم يقفوا مكتوفي الأيدي، فشاركت التجريدة المغربية
وقوات صدام حسين وجزائر هواري بو مدين، وليبيا القذافي،
فيما قررت السعودية قطع النفط عن أمريكا حتى تخرج إسرائيل من الأراضي العربية،
وشارك العرب عموما بهذا الانتصار المصري،،،،
عندما يجتمع العرب في جبهة واحدة، فهذا يعني الانتصار حتما
سيظل الندم  الإسرائيلي على قرار الحرب مع مصر قائما
ويبدو أن إسرائيل لن تجرؤ  في المستقبل على خوض حرب
يكون فيها المصريون الطرف المقابل لها